keeping in the theme of fall we are
talking all things fashion food even
journaling and here to get us ready for
the new season is lifestyle expert
Samantha Vickers and we are matching
today I know we didn't even plan it we
didn't plan it we were just meant to do
this interview I always love seeing you
because you come with the best stuff and
there's a lot on those table so let's
get right to it let's start over here so
fall means cooler weather temperatures
so that means baking at my house so I
had to bring the essentials of great
baking which is your tools so what I
brought today is nutrimill I brought
down here is the artiste mixer and this
is the classic Grain Mill and so this is
a compact little mixer but it's going to
give a powerful punch with all of the
baked goods that you're making this will
make it so that everything is more
nutritious and delicious okay well I was
thinking pumpkin bread in my mind but
maybe something a little healthier you
can make between all of that so you can
find these and so much more on
nutrimil.com awesome all right let's
move on over here all right so Fall's
busy we all know that um but we don't
have to sacrifice is our health and
nutrition so live Eden one is amazing
and it helps us to get all of that in
without you know going crazy so it is
actually the world's most complete
superfood with over 60 different
ingredients to help balance and um
nurture our bodies yeah you can see
everything on the back here it says
everything from multivitamin immune
support Prebiotic yeah the list goes on
and on about something really great yes
and this you can find at liveedon.com
and it's great for the whole family so
even my little ones can take it up to
you know my husband my grandma can take
it anybody so it's great for the whole
family all right now are we talking
fashion we are we are this is oh I'll
put it up right here pink desert love
pink desert whether you are just
accessorizing which I have here or if
you're going for a whole new outfit pink
desert has got you covered you can go in
the store which is in the Northwest and
Shop in store or you can go online at
thepinkdesert.com and you're going to be
able to find all these fun things and I
love Darcy she is amazing amazing
entrepreneur started this over 12 years
ago in her home and now look at it it's
amazing it is just blown up I see
everyone locally especially on social
media is always wearing her stuff and I
love that hats are having a moment
because they're everywhere now okay what
do we have next okay and I had to bring
something that's just kind of a DIY
really it's a habit and it is daily
journaling and gratitude journaling and
so while we're going into fall it's a
great time to look back on what we're
grateful for so choose a time of day
that you can sit and write down just
three things that you're grateful for
that's uh yep and you can find more tips
and tricks on this kind of stuff on my
Instagram at samiam Vickers or my
website is samanthavickers.com yeah I
love following along with you on social
media you always have so many helpful
tidbits and things to get and you always
come with the best apps so Samantha
thank you so much for being here again
follow her on social media she is
awesome and JC I'll send it over to you